>> Dana: IT IS DAY 31 OF THE
PARTIAL SHUTDOWN AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BLASTING
DEMOCRATS FOR REJECTING HIS
PROPOSAL TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESIDENT OFFERING UP
PROTECTIONS FOR DACA SAPIENS IN
EXCHANGE FOR BORDER WALL FUNDING
THE DEMOCRATS REFUSING TO BUDGE.
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER RAMPING UP
THEIR RHETORIC WHILE SLAMMING
TRUMP'S COMPROMISE.
>> IF HE OPENS UP THE
GOVERNMENT, WE WILL DISCUSS
WHATEVER HE OFFERS BUT
HOSTAGETAKING WILL NOT WORK.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY AGAINST IT.
THE PRESIDENT'S POLL RANKINGS
ARE PLUMMETING BECAUSE EVEN HIS
OWN SUPPORTERS AGREE IT'S A BAD
TACTIC.
IT'S HARD TO NEGOTIATE WHEN A
GUN IS HELD TO YOUR HEAD.
>> Dana: SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL SAYS HE'S
GOING TO BRING UP TRUMP'S PLAN
FOR A VOTE THIS WEEKEND A MOMENT
AGO, 13 MINUTES AGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED ABOUT
THE WALL AND HE SAID:
"IF NANCY PELOSI THINKS THAT
WALLS ARE "IMMORAL," WHY ISN'T
SHE REQUESTING THAT WE TAKE DOWN
ALL OF THE EXISTING WALLS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND MEXICO,
EVEN THE NEW ONES JUST BUILT IN
SAN DIEGO AT THEIR VERY STRONG
URGING.
LET MILLIONS OF UNCHECKED
"STRANGERS" JUST FLOW
INTO THE U.S."
THAT ACTUALLY WAS A QUESTION
THAT I WANTED TO ASK GREG WHICH
IS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID AT
THE WALL IS AMORAL.
SO IF YOU ARE THERE, HOW DO YOU
NEGOTIATE GETTING TO BORDER
SECURITY?
>> Greg: I SAID THIS LAST
WEEK.
I SAID THAT THEY SHOULD REMOVE
THE WALL BETWEEN MEXICO.
I THINK I SAID THIS LAST WEEK.
IS IT AMORAL OR IMMORAL?
>> Dana: YOU TELL ME.
YOU'RE THE EDITOR.
>> Greg: IT IS IMMORAL.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
THE MORE TRUMP NEGOTIATES WITH
PRACTICAL COMPROMISES, THE MORE
INFANTILE AND PERSONAL THE
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE TAKING IT
BUT THEY STARTED AT THE WRONG
END.
THEY SHOULD BEGIN -- THE PRISON
OF TWO IDEAS.
WE KEEP SAYING YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
ONE POSITION.
YOU ARE FOR IMMIGRATION OR
AGAINST IMMIGRATION.
THAT IS BALONEY.
YOU CAN HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT POSITIONS ON
IMMIGRATION.
FOR EXAMPLE, I AM
PRO-IMMIGRATION.
I AM PRO-REFUGEE WITH EXTREME
VETTING.
I DON'T SEE -- REFUGEES MAKE
GREAT CITIZENS BECAUSE THEY ARE
GRATEFUL.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE EXTREME
VETTING BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
IF THERE'S GOING TO BE
TERRORISTS COMING IN.
I AM LIVING OUTSIDE OF THIS
PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
WE ARE STUCK IN THIS THING WHERE
YOU HAVE TO BE THIS FOR THIS.
IT IS KILLING THE DEBATE.
>> Dana: THE OTHER RHETORICAL
EXCESS I NOTICED THIS WEEKEND IS
DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TAKING HOSTAGES.
AGAIN, IT'S LIKE WOW.
EVERY REALLY TALKING ABOUT THAT?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY.
THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION ON THE
WALL.
HOSTAGETAKING, THAT'S TAKING IT
TO A NEW EXTREME.
>> Jesse: SCHUMER SAID WE WILL
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT AND WE
CAN'T EVEN DISCUSS BORDER
SECURITY UNTIL YOU DO THAT.
WELL, THE PRESIDENT OFFERED
NANCY PELOSI THAT.
HE SAID IF WE REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT, CAN WE DO A DEAL ON
A BARRIER LATER ON?
YOU KNOW SHE SAID, NO.
THEN HE SAID BYE-BYE AND THAT
WAS THE TIME HE WALKED OUT OF
THE ROOM.
GREG BRINGS UP THE POINT YOU SAY
OVER THE WALL, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO SAY WE ARE AGAINST THE
WALL.
THUS, EVERY REPORTER SHOULD BE
ASKING THAT VERY QUESTION.
CONGRESSWOMAN, SENATOR, DO YOU
BELIEVE WE SHOULD TEAR DOWN THE
EXISTING WALL SINCE THEY ARE
IMMORAL AND THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T
WORK?
YOU WOULD HAVE THE GOVERNMENT
REOPENED RIGHT NOW IF WE HAD A
FAIR MEDIA IN THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE ASKING
THESE LOGICAL QUESTIONS TO
DEMOCRATS BY NOT PROTECTING THE
DEMOCRATIC POSITION, AND THE
INTENSITY WOULD BE SO STRONG I
NANCY, SHE WOULD HAVE TO COME TO
THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
I BELIEVE SHE HAS LOST THIS
ARGUMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT HER GETTING
GROUNDED ON THE FLIGHT, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PUERTO RICAN P.R.
DISASTER.
TRUMP MODERATING HIS POSITION.
THE LOGICAL ARGUMENTS, THEY JUST
CAN'T ARGUE IT.
ALL THEY SAY IS IT'S MEAN.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HE'S
OFFERING, HE'S OFFERING
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
HE'S OFFERING CHANGES TO THE
ASYLUM.
HE SAYS 280 ADDITIONAL WALLS TO
BE NEEDED AND BUILT.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING?
NO AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE
STILL NOT GETTING PAID.
I DON'T THINK IT'S VERY
COMPASSIONATE.
>> Dana: JUAN, THE DEMOCRATS
DON'T SEEM TO THINK THEY ARE
LOSING.
>> Juan: THEY ARE NOT LOSING.
JESSE, IF THIS WAS ABOUT THE
MEDIA, I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT
THE MEDIA.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS STAND AND WHAT HE
CONSIDERS TO BE A POLITICAL
SYMBOL HE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE
ON.
THEY MIGHT SAY I THOUGHT
MITCH MCCONNELL, REPUBLICANS
JOINED IN SAYING LET'S KEEP THE
GOVERNMENT OPEN.
LET'S KEEP PEOPLE GETTING PAID,
KEEP THE ECONOMY GROWING, AND
THEN NEGOTIATE.
INITIALLY WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAY?
AND THEN HE SAID NO BECAUSE THE
PRESSURE FROM THE RIGHT BRING
TALK SHOW HOSTS OR MAYBE THE
MEDIA.
IF YOU HAD A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY
FOR TWO YEARS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE'S AND IT DIDN'T SEEM TO
BE A PRIORITY, DID IT?
NOW HE GOES AFTER NANCY PELOSI'S
RADICAL.
RADICAL?
WHAT IS RADICAL HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT HAS A WEAK NEGOTIATING
HAND AND I THINK IT IS STARTING
TO SHOW.
I THINK PEOPLE WERE DISAPPOINTED
WITH WHAT CAME ON SATURDAY.
EVERYONE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO
BE A BIG ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> Greg: THEY DIDN'T LIKE WHAT
HE OFFERED.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
>> Greg: THIS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
WOULD WANT.
>> Juan: ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE SAID JESSE WAS SAYING TO ME
LAST WEEK, JUAN, IF IT SO EASY,
TELL ME WHAT YOU WANT.
GUESS WHAT, THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT WE WANT MORE
TECHNOLOGY, MORE BORDER AGENTS,
MORE JUDGES.
HE SOUNDS LIKE HE STARTING TO
NEGOTIATE ON THE DEMOCRATS
TERMS.
BUT HE DOESN'T SAY I'M GOING TO
STOP THIS SHUTDOWN.
>> Jedediah: THIS IS HOW YOU
STOP IT.
ORIGINALLY HE WAS JUST TALKING
ABOUT A WALL AND HE SAID -- I
SAID IT WAS A MISTAKE BECAUSE HE
WAS ONLY PROMISED ON THE WALL.
NOW BECOMES THE TABLE AND SAYS
WE NEED THESE BARRIERS BUT I'M
GONNA PROVIDE THE HUMANITARIAN
AID.
>> Greg: GAVE AN EXTENDED --
REDUCE THE IMMIGRATION.
>> Jedediah: JUAN.
TO COME ON BOARD, THEY WOULD
HAVE TO REMOVE -- HE WOULD HAVE
TO SAY I'M NOT INTERESTED IN THE
STILL BARRIERS OF THE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS HAVE ASKED FOR.
HE WOULD HAVE TO REMOVE THE
COMPONENT OF THE WALL IN ORDER
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO GET ON
BOARD.
THEY WANT TO DENY HIM THAT
TALKING POINT.
HE MADE A CAMPAIGN PROMISE AND
IF HE INCLUDES THE BORDER
SECURITY MEASURE IN THERE.
>> Juan: THE PROMISE HE MADE